how do I get the desire to have
discipline how do I get the desire to
have discipline there I keep getting
asked this type of question how do I get
discipline or how do I want discipline
or how do I maintain discipline and the
answer it's it's a simple answer but
obviously it's not easy and there's all
kinds of little tricks and methods that
people talk about and you know they have
some merit
you know maybe they do work these these
things you know do the little things
people say and wake up early I say that
and write things down and take cold
showers and tell everyone what you're
going to do so broadcast it and make
promises or or make bets with with your
friends of something that you don't want
to lose and those things those ideas
they're cool I'm sure they're gonna have
some impact and if they work for you
that's that's awesome but but the fact
of the matter is that the reason
discipline is hard to maintain is
because it is hard to maintain that's
what makes discipline hard it's hard and
if you hear me claim that discipline is
easy for me then straight up
that's just my ego talking that's what
that is because I'm unfortunately just
as human as everyone else and it is work
to maintain the discipline that's what
it is work holding the line maintaining
the standard giving no slack none that's
the discipline
that's the discipline and it is hard and
if there's one thing I would say that
does make it easier it's to envision
what it feels like when you're done what
it feels like after you've worked out or
you've held the line on your food intake
or you've pushed through some monotonous
project that you have to do in all those
things when they're done that they feel
good and contrary to that envision what
you will feel like later when you let
the discipline slack you know the
feeling feeling weak and defeated and
you know that you're falling behind so
get to know those two different types of
feelings and ask yourself which one you
want to feel in ten minutes
or in a half an hour when when the thing
is done when the discipline has Blin
implemented remember what that feels
like and then remember that those
minutes and those hours they turn into
weeks and months and years and holding
the line in those critical minutes will
put you in an infinitely better place
physically and mentally if you maintain
the discipline so work through the
weakness fight through the temptation
hold the line hold the line
maintain the discipline it is not easy
but it is worth it because yes because
discipline equals freedom